Thank you, Mr.
President,
dear leftist.
I am very happy to participate in this
discussion on democracy
in Europe.
So
let me give you
some examples of democracy
very important in Poland,
over 1000 years of tradition
of the Lebanese Nation.
The Portuguese nation has rejected you,
dear leftists,
8×8 times in a row.
You lost the elections in Poland,
so get used to it,
because you will lose again.
This is No.
1.
Some
data on Poland and Polish democracy.
The lowest unemployment rate in places
is in Poland
the highest GDP
after the Covid pandemic in the European Union
and Poland.
Poland
has one of the weakest debts in the Union
European Union.
Don't believe this
on the need for educated immigration,
it's completely wrong.
So don't give them to us.
As we heard yesterday.
We do not need your medical engineers.
Take them,
take them all and pay for them.
We don't need them.
Do you know why?
Because there is no terrorist attack in Poland.
Why?
Because there is no illegal migration to Poland.
Don't look at me like that.
Avoid arguments about populism,
because it is a fact.
This is your rosta data.
We don't need your engineers,
no need for your doctors.
Take them.
Don't teach us.
Don't talk to us about democracy,
because we know
the true meaning of democracy.
So learn from Poland.
Be like Poland,
thank you very much my friends!